he gets out of office after being
elected not once but twice with 83
approval so if you have to make an
assessment and share with us what what
would you say that he actually did right
during the time that he was a president
to come out with that kind of right now
right now bolsonaro bolsonaro is is a 50
which represents you know I mean the the
country is divided but he obviously did
a few things right for the whole country
what were you the country is divided and
if you look at the poor parts of the
Brazil That's where Lula still has uh
some relevance But to answer you it's
important to go back to 2003 correct and
remember what happened to the world it
was uh the China play like Brazil is a
Commodities uh country and we export a
lot of uh uh food and all that and China
is a main partner so uh what happened is
that Brazil was able to inflate its
economy it was not sustainable and
that's very important to understand
because what happened after Lula gave
money to everybody and the credit was a
very let me let me give you a number
okay to to what he's saying uh when Lula
took office uh Brazil the federal
government budget was 600 roughly 600
billion Brazilian cash okay
when Duma was impeached the federal
budget was 1.4 trillion
so
they the the one of the reasons is
because of what Rodrigo is saying
because of the wealth that the exporting
Commodities to China and and the
development of the country the federal
government had more than twice as as
much money as they used to during Lula's
and Dumas uh term and even though Juma
was a huge failure but people uh don't
necessarily uh associate it with Lula so
that that's part of the answer but to
tell you the truth I don't believe Lula
has this kind of popularity right now we
don't see that on the streets we see
bolsonaro's fans but we don't see lulas
the the issue is that a lot especially
the the upper classes they hate
bolsonaro so the the vote to vote in
Lula is not necessarily to want him back
is that you want bolsonaro out of it so
it that's part of this and I understand
what you're saying but but remove China
for a moment right and and I understand
everything that you're saying on terms
so that injection or capital everything
comes out the fact of the matter I want
to go back to that point it's important
though right because what we're trying
to do is we want to make sure that we we
do have an honest approach to the whole
situation right now you know what I mean
by the way I was born in Honduras so I
know corruption and I'm willing to
accept that a lot easier than most
people I think in this country and even
Latin America right now are behaving
naively when it comes to this point
however however
it can't just be China though he was
able to do a number of things run so I'm
asking you can you name a few things
that you will say that he absolutely did
right I can yeah yeah I think I think
Bosa Familia which is a a a program of
social well welfare uh distribution and
so it was like a food stamp program in
Brazil he implemented that he was most
people were against it I was as well in
the beginning it was more on the liberal
side of the economy you were younger
younger exactly that was uh and and uh
it was that was that was a good program
it was very important uh program to
Brazil for people uh there are in
Desperate condition and again because he
had more money he was able to do a lot
of uh public projects and that's a lot
of it but the the main reason if you ask
me the main reason I would have to tell
you
so Reuters okay they publish a report
every year
about the trusts in the media okay how
much people trust in the media if you if
you get the numbers in the U.S right now
they're around 20 20 of the people trust
the mainstream media most of the time
that's correct that's the the general
number in the US if you if you take
Republicans this number is under 10
right now
in Brazil in 2009 okay under Lulu's
government that number was 70 percent
right now it's 48 this year so media
media media's trust is Plumbing in
Brazil right now but it's still 48 48 of
Brazilian people trust the media which
is
extremely liberal or leftist to be more
precise
I know you interviewed Jordan Peterson I
like to be precise uh
so so and Global because of the wrong
reasons they want money to tell you the
truth that's what's behind it they want
money bolsonaro was not given as much
money as Lula so uh they they are
against bolsonaro Global lies every day
to the public and there is a huge
influence and Marvin you mentioned
Honduras and it's very important to
understand that in Latin America and
look at our neighbors in Brazil they are
all left winged right now they are very
very radical left-wing governments right
now the photo de Sao Paulo is very
important to understand Lula started it
in nine in the 90s uh with uh Fidel
Castro and uh uh there there are many
poor people in Brazil uh they don't know
a lot about communism correct so it's
it's easy to to attract those kind of
people in Brazil with those lies with
populism and that's what happened so
Lula is still a little bit popular but
we don't see that on the streets that's
very important to to to to bring here
because uh we see the numbers so with
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetaining
it says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]